me now you have had to navigate one of
the most
challenging moments for uh wokeness in
america
killing various comedians and and
canceling them over
uh jokes when it comes to their careers
threatening them in all manner of
different ways how have you been able to
resist the urge to just bend the knee
and go along with it
well i just want to say first off ben
that this this live
tv game is very stressful they abducted
me into a van
and i can't see you so basically i'm
used to doing podcasting in a dungeon
in terms of i mean listen people people
were always
getting mad that's been happening since
the beginning of time but comedy is the
same when you go on the clubs it's the
same
you just get yelled at a little bit more
after the fact in the clubs
and there is kind of this thing where
you know
people are allowed to not like something
but that's what normally comedy is you
make a joke and the audience laughs or
doesn't laugh
but yeah there's definitely right now
people want to add in a new thing where
they go i didn't like that so no one
else should like it or whatever but
the truth is audiences aren't actually
that mean
because people think that you know when
people talk about like punching down on
all those concepts
there is some truth to that stuff i mean
you know if you if we go to a club and
i'm saying the meat is stuffed to some
guy everyone goes whoa i don't want to
hear this why is this guy being a jerk
right but if but a lot of times you're
not actually making fun of the thing
you're making fun of the person that
tells you you can't say it like if
you're
okay think about this if you're if
you're at school and the teacher goes
listen
you called someone called someone four
eyes and then the teacher goes no one
could say that again we made a rule
anyone who says four eyes is expelled
and and
and and you're kicked out of school and
we're gonna ruin your life you just made
calling someone four eyes the funniest
thing you could possibly do
so i think that's what's happening with
a lot of this stuff i mean they say that
and then it's never about the thing it
just becomes about the person that's
telling you what to say and comedians
kind of generally don't like to be told
what to do comedy has been a
big respite for me during this entire
pandemic
you know turning to try to find some
some joy and some funny things in it
your weekly videos have been a major
part of that
for me and so i'm very grateful for all
of them my friends share them around
everybody sends them to each other and i
just have to ask you
have you gotten feedback from people who
are responding to you just saying
thank you for saying this thing thank
you for being willing to mock something
that other people are scared of mocking
yeah i get gift baskets daily i'm very
popular everyone's
everyone's very impressed with what i'm
doing yeah i mean that's kind of the
thing
you go to clubs and normal people just
kind of want to see comedy and
comedy's sort of a casualty in this
whole you know war that's going on or
whatever because
you know people want to tell you what
you can't say and comedians have a
tendency to say the things you're not
supposed to say so they
want to stop that you know what i mean
but at the end of the day it's like
you're just trying to make funny things
and people are gonna have a problem with
that and that's fine they're allowed to
you know i feel like this has been such
a difficult year for comedians because
they've had to navigate
the shutdown the lockdowns that have
prevented them from being able
to work in the kind of close-knit clubs
that
you know i heard hear all of these
people reminiscing about the
the days that they used to have now that
the clubs are starting to open back up
again
have you been performing yourself what's
it been like to come out
and actually be in front of a crowd
again
yeah and well i was touring all the
places that were open before but new
york i live in new york and new york's
back so i'm doing
uh two shows tonight three shows
tomorrow so the clubs are back and
everyone's pumped to be there so yeah
it's cool
well i feel like that isn't one of those
environmental things
that coming back will give us a sense of
normalcy in
a certain way you know being able to
just get out there and laugh at some
jokes together to blow off some steam
is something that a lot of people were
unable to do during this pandemic
would you encourage them to come and and
see
these performers in live again just as a
way to try to
support them after such a long time
well i think one of the biggest problems
with that is because of the pandemic
everyone lived their lives online and
then you start thinking that's real life
and then you go back out and you go all
right people are just normal
you know the fact that you know if you
before you know i don't care who's the
president which i think is probably an
advantage in comedy like it doesn't
matter to me
so you're the one you would say that
before i mean what you don't yeah what
then you go no and people are just
normal people so i think that going back
into clubs
i think some of the people that you know
felt that they were in their little
bubble online and they're you know
getting mad at everyone and arguing with
people all day long
then you kind of go outside and you're
back around people and you go oh yeah
everyone's kind of fine this is fine
you were a punk rocker before you were a
comedian how has that informed your
comedy
um i think that everything that i've
done has had some sort of trouble you
know oriented
so i think that that's one of the
reasons i like that's why i liked
america i'm from canada right and i
moved here
and one of the things is canada's so
small that doesn't really have room for
a kind of counter culture
to kind of flourish so you know you
talked about the you know
woe comedy or whatever you're talking
about like what you really mean is the
mainstream you know comedy and what
the same thing you have that in
journalism and have that everywhere
here's the
main narrative and everyone can decide
what that's going to be but then
america is big enough that there's room
for all this other stuff and especially
with the internet
so i think that's one of the things i
you know i like about it here
ryan long thank you so much for taking
the time to join me and
thank you so much for giving us some
laughter during the
during the pandemic hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else